I'm leaving l'viv because I lost my job
at the Philharmonic gem flea Ukraine cuz
my firm went bankrupt I'm going away to
earn money for my family
Svetlana who Yana Polina and alia are
the girls from the viv they have
millions of Polish TV viewers glued to
their sets every Sunday night the collec
use have followed the Ukrainians
exploits as cleaning ladies in Poland
from the start it's really exciting so
you just have to keep watching there's
always something happening we've had
Ukrainian cleaning ladies ourselves but
I never considered what their stories
were that's precisely why girls from
l'viv has proven so popular most poles
have employed a Ukrainian cleaning lady
the series shows how times have changed
not long ago many Poles headed west to
Germany or the UK to clean other
people's homes now the poles have become
wealthy and for Ukrainians exemplify
western-style capitalism like the image
and I live in a city now we're on the
opposite side of the fence we're the
employers enough to hire people from
poorer countries but really this is a
comedy about the poles and how they
react to foreigners the series employs
many stereotypes the Ukrainians are
young pretty and dependent on their
polish employers spent lonna cleans for
a wealthy lawyer for her he's a good
catch but all he does is ocol her who's
constantly tyrannize by her employer
poles like to watch the show because it
lets them feel superior
this sociologist says his many studies
show that Polish women in particular
take advantage of the Ukrainians
weakness and dependency to boost their
own self-esteem they're always finding
fault with them and want to discipline
them
Lavanya many Ukrainian women find
themselves in this position because
they're working in Poland illegally and
the series shows this some have to take
what comes for instance a job cleaning
house in the nude in the series Polina
can defend herself but in reality that's
not always possible
Tatiana has lived in Poland for five
years
she's cleaned and babysat for folks who
didn't always treat her well ferries
most of my experiences have been
positive but I've had a couple of really
bad ones - really awful and once I was
attacked on the streets by nationalists
maybe girls from the viv will change
that if poles are sympathetic to the
Ukrainian TV characters they might
become more accepting of their real-life
counterparts the Ukrainian cleaning
ladies hold up a mirror to polish
society at least that's the intention of
the show's director and I suppose if I'm
in touch we need to be a word it's a
cleaner hose sweeping or mopping up he's
a human being with emotions and personal
problems of their own
yesterday's problem there girls from the
viv is group therapy disguised as a TV
show it's packaged well enough that it
might just work